He just keep reading. He could just keep reading. If Tommy C
decided to make a rocket to go to Mars and compete with SpaceX,
he would obviously make something that's useless to everybody.
Would not be a market replacement. But if he declared that whatever
he made, whatever explosive random IED he made was a competitor,
that wouldn't make it a competitor. How did he say there's three
when he's reading a chat that says there's four? He read this
symbol as three. I'm That's amazing.
H
I don't think this guy makes money off his streaming. I think
he basically just booches off of his wife. When he has no point,
he falls back on laughing at something that nobody else would
ever find funny uh or accusing the person making the point of
taking this too seriously while simultaneously
um himself litigating drama against someone in a serious manner
uh and then saying, "Oh, don't take it seriously. Just tube
>> I'll check out this I'll check out this Tommy C thing.
Apparently Tommy C commented on those tweets around Willie Mack.
We'll just see if he uh we'll see what he says. >> It's
incredibly
obvious that this didn't really read the lawsuit.
that is incredibly obvious that he didn't read the lawsuit >> arguments.
Well, here's the thing with both of them. I This is neither of
them are lawyers. This and I know this guy's a
he gets involved with the victims he >> Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. I also that's just so stupid. I was friends with Cherry
for a long time before any of that happened. He gets involved
with the victims he helped. The There's a reason Cherry talked
to me about it, right? It's so stupid. It's such a thing to say.
God, people are so dumb.
But uh you don't have to be a lawyer to know that what Willy's
saying is stupid.
>> You literally don't at all.
>> And they're all just going to call each other stupid.
No one's going to learn
>> Yeah. If you read the loss of princ the show Ethan's
arguments and the reason
why snark and
>> this guy was friends and ran a show with this person
for like a year and then
for some reason got involved when he found out that a mutual
had done like a crime to them
and that means that they that any relationship past that point
is now
>> Hate him so much if you
think
proposing for only transformation with doesn't help you. Um,
he could certainly be your opinion. I will say this, I did find
that thing weird, but I'm not a lawyer and neither is Jtock
>> and he's Canadian to boot. Well, everybody's a >> Okay.
Well, you know what? I really hope Cherry's not in chat right
now.
>> Just in case Cherry is there. In case Cherry were to
say something. Okay, throw that out there immediately. >> A
legal expert. You don't have to be a legal expert to know that
for a defamation lawsuit in which they are using those pictures
to to go after Hassan the Hun on like the thinnest most justification.
You don't have to be a legal expert to know that that's stupid.
>> The entirety of um Ali Gusini reference Hassan the son
Ali Gusini. It doesn't
>> allege he works with >> Oh, he's trying to read.
Uhoh.
You know what? I right right here I actually have to give it
up to Tommy C a little bit. Okay, I actually do. He's actually
going to read this.
I would not have expected that. So I will I will give a little
respect. I'll put a little respect on Tommy C's name. Okay, he's
actually going to read and try to see like what is the point
being made here. I like that. We'll see if he actually reads
the article segment and see if like that's the only reason they
they reference this. and we'll see what he actually says >> to
include two pictures he's working with two points which is on
what legal school are you going to >> what where's the
legal I'm not making a legal argument I'm not making a legal
argument there's no legal argument being made there's no there's
not a legal argument dude if if you are suing if you were suing
somebody for defamation and you included a picture of a chicken
okay
and said that somebody who's friends with the person you're suing
kind of looks like a chicken so here's a picture of a chicken,
I would also think you're and if a lawyer came to me and said,
"No, no, no. That's really important because even though them
being a chicken isn't really relevant to anything, um they need
to know that like well technically technically the chicken has
bad feelings towards the plaintiff and pos it's like bro I if
they compare denims to Al Husseini maybe the pictures don't need
to be there to begin with but it's funny because they it's funny
to me because in the actual lawsuit they say Al Husseini worked
with the and that's where he's different from Hassan. Like they
say it. You just read the text and they say >> which Ali
is saying are similar. It's not the I bet that's not even the
point of putting it in there.
>> What? I included it in the I included the picture. Hold
on. We'll see. Tommy has all of the power here to actually go
through this and figure out what's going on. I gave all the information
is right
>> It's right there. I bet that's not even I bet that's
not even why they included it. No, it is
>> number one. They're both passionate. highly charismatic
leaders or the pro Palestinian guys to they both in essence advocate
for the annihilation of
>> the difference cited for point two and now like you
see this wouldn't even be discussed in a court
is there okay Tommy is totally on my side let's go >> the
problem is >> yeah nobody nobody knows what to talk about
nobody knows this would I I doubt this would be discussed
you you would I I think it's best if
one the um the prosecuting attorney. It's not really >> Why
does he just keep reading? He could just keep reading. >> The
prosecutor would would explain why he put it in there. Like this
guy is an anti-semite, which by the way isn't illegal. And uh
this is his motivation for sending all this hate my way. Whether
that's actionable, whether I don't know.
>> Son's not a defendant in the lawsuit.
uh hate being sent his way is like not actually what's being
litigated at all. >> It's a copyright infringement lawsuit.
>> But but Jay Stalk knows. He's a genius. >> It's
a critical He didn't even read it. >> It sounds to me like
he just has a different opinion. You can't you can't
>> No, it's it says if you read the lawsuit, it seems pretty
obvious it's there to show Ethan's arguments and the reason why
Snark and Denims hate him so much. It's not there to show Ethan's
arguments. It's there to say Hassan's kind of like an
aren't even required,
right? The pictures are not required because the pictures of
Husseini working with a thing that they don't allege Hassan did.
So why are you including pictures of Husini working with when
you've already said uh you've already cited the Wikipedia page
for him? >> You you can't attack his opinion, so you're
just going to call him stupid? Well, speaking of stupid.
>> Yeah, look at this. In 2024,
>> this is another genius. Uh, 2024, Nicholas Story was
close with Chud Logic and had no problem saying people that abuse
a copyright who do lawsuits silence criticism. I mean, >> it's
just two separate
we'll get into that. But but here's the thing.
If you can you like you could you're allowed to lose in court.
You're allowed to file a lawsuit.
There's nothing illegal here. No one's first amendment rights
being violated. Um, >> Change fair use for everybody is
dangerous. Then back off.
>> This is I don't even know if this is about court. I
think this is about uh silencing criticism via the DMCA system,
right? Which is a totally different
That's that's got to be what this one's about, right? I don't
think this is about the Willie lawsuit anymore. >> Dark
Viper Udama. Now he's cozing up to Ethan Klein where he's been
pretty clear that he's not comfortable with the lawsuit. So we're
leaving that out. says thing, well, I have no sympathy for people
like Tamat Fence
uh Demons because they were mean to me, which he never I'm sure
he never said more or less. Uh the guy is embarrassing. Yeah,
I guess. So, let's let's see what he put in for evidence.
>> Garen [__] T. That is the thing that him
off because I don't like react content. I just think that Dark
Viper is a net negative. I think he's worse than Hassan. I think
he's worse than Asmin Gold. I think people who abuse the copyright
system because they're fragile little and threaten to do multi-
overseas lawsuits to silence uh this is a different thing since
signal just so we're clear. This is um this is probably in response
to Ethan DMCAing clips from like uh H3 Snark or H3 Lefto Leftovers
H3 or whatever, right? I think that's what this is about. And
those clips are like small snippets, like 30 second snippets
or like two-minute snippets basically to highlight criticism.
And so the post would be saying, "Hey, this is like we're we're
critiquing this." That would be in itself like uh transformative
in my opinion. So if he's DMCA those to silence criticism, that's
probably something that Nicholas is speaking out about here.
And then we would wonder if that transfers over to the criticism
of Ethan Klein or not. criticism because their whole dream is
to get the copyright
ruling in a court of law and change fair use for everybody else.
Uh, I think that person is dangerous. I think that person is
a bad person. And I think >> and didn't Ethan make it abundantly
clear that he's not trying to change. Although, by the way, in
fairness, he might get it changed and he doesn't want to. I'm
not super thrilled about the lawsuit. This is a completely different
situation, which look what it Yeah. that their footprint is worse
than any lazy reactor who's stealing content. Yes, I think Asmin
Gold is the lesser of two evils. And I would kind of saying that
like Matt Hos versus Ethan Klein was was a thing like using 3
minutes of a 17minute work and like commenting over it for an
extended period of time. It's not exactly going to be like comparable
to someone watching a full hour and a half video while farting
on camera. That's not like the thing. I don't know. I have a
a really hard time feeling bad for these people even like depending
on how this goes because like we've been telling these Twitch
streamers for
>> Oh, I see. This is not the same argument. There's a
way better argument against Aoro on this front if you're going
to use the Dark Viper comparison cuz I think Ethan has done basically
exactly what Dark Viper's done as well. Um and and the arguments
against that are pretty easy and the arguments for it are pretty
yikesy.
Probably not as much on this one.
He does the same defense for the subreddit posts with the little
clips and it doesn't work as well. For the denim stuff, you could
argue it's a violation of copyright in actuality
and they're just smug rude to us. And it's like, well, now exactly
what we said is happening, but it's coming from Ethan Klein.
So, it's conflicting. I guess if
Master Chef came and did this years ago, I don't think that anybody
would be defending them over it. Everyone was telling them what
they were going to do was going to lead to a like ad apocalypse
or something like that. like what you said. What a great comparison.
Kai, you're a genius. You're a genius. And he's, by the way,
he gets >> I would say it's probably okay, right? It's
okay to what do you call it? It's probably okay to say that that
seems like hypocrisy. I don't think that's the bigger hypocrisy.
I think the bigger hypocrisy is, you know, if you're aware of
Ethan Klein DMCAing all these small clips that are basically
just criticism, like valid criticism because he doesn't like
the subreddit, I would say
that's something you should call out. That's something that would
be against Nicholas's morals.
Yeah. Did YouTube change their policy that's going to essentially
more or less nuke the commentary community or reaction community?
No. That there that policy is only meant to apply to like AI
like spammed content. It's not meant to apply broadly to like
commentary or any kind of content like that. That content is
still all fully monetizable. There's no real problem there as
far as I know.
>> Yeah, I'm pretty sure that's the case. So, yep, yep,
yep, yep, yep, yep, yep. Now, do JTO talking about the Destiny
Orbiter machine transition to cherry tweets exposing him for
the victims he platforms and institutionalize them when they
speak out about it. Okay,
that's an incredible way to uh to describe that situation. I
bet that person has, you know, gone and tweeted and been like,
"Oh, I was kind of wrong about what I said back here." Right?
Very good faith actor, I would imagine.
C certainly almost almost certainly
was okay with the Bobax content and argued for archiving content.
Sure, archiving content is not what Denims was doing though,
Signal. I don't think I'd make that criticism of Nick. I don't
think archiving content is what Denims was doing at all. Anyway,
that's I think that's it for the Tommy C stuff. Wait, hold on.
Let me just check real quick and make sure
>> real quick. >> If Denims gets off, it's probably
good for what a great comparison, Kai. You're a genius. >> Well,
we'll listen to And he's, by the way, he gets roasted in the
comments here. Nice false equivalently read our trudge reaction
was made to be transformative, not a replacement for Denims and
others.
>> There's like a way better argument here. And there's
like some evidence that Nick
knew about those small clips getting DMCA and didn't really do
it.
Yeah, there's it's just I could go over it at some point. Hold
on. Let me let me just see.
Hold on. Um um um um Oh, I should probably prepare it if I was
going to go over it. But there's basically just some evidence
that Ethan Klein went and DMC some smaller creators. And that's
probably like really against what Nick's morals are on the topic.
quite honestly admitted to stealing it for the intention of >> I
actually think that Nick reviewed that criticism and said like
he was fine with it. He doesn't feel bad for them >> acting
as a replacement. Not not defending Ethan Klein in any way there.
It's just the the situation is different from Chud Logic who
did make a fair use thing or at least we think >> I I think
he's been consistent and here >> well Chud's argument was
basically like although it's not the perfect argument I did provide
lots of commentary here you like transformed the video he's like
oh I increased the length quite a bit and for Ethan he said oh
well I don't want to go after these people doing good faith reactions
right like Asmin Gold XQC
and Denim's reaction was almost certainly more transformative
than XQC's was So Ethan's problem is not fair use or transformativity,
right? It's just that Denim said you Ethan, give me a like if
you didn't like giving a view to that video or something. Or
if you if you like not giving a view to that video, give me a
like. Throw me a sub, right? That's what Ethan didn't like. And
that's probably not a part of fair use. Probably probably >> thing.
My argument with him is look, let the not that so much the denims
of the world go, but if they get off, it's probably if denims
gets off, it's probably good for reactors in general. But when
he was going after was her name Sniper Wolf, um he said, Nick
said, "Mate, that's not fair use." And then we got in an argument
over it and and and what have you. But my thing was, yes, let
her get away with it. Right. And uh yeah, that >> hold
on, hold on, hold on. Ryle in chat, malice doesn't matter in
the lawsuit and isn't a part of fair use. It is a part of fair
use if you tell them that you are making it with the explicit
means. No, the market the market analysis is like totally dispassionate
>> of acting as a replacement which isn't allowed in fair.
>> No intent doesn't define a replacement a market replacement.
It literally >> That's not fair. That's literally I'm making
this as a replacement. I'm making this to drive traffic away.
That's not fair use.
>> Um okay. If Tommy C decided to make a rocket to go to
Mars and compete with SpaceX, he would obviously make something
that's useless to everybody, would not be a market replacement.
But if he declared that whatever he made, whatever explosive
random IED he made was a competitor, that wouldn't make it a
competitor. Okay?
>> It's you're not a competitor because you say so. You're
a competitor based on a dispassionate analysis. I do think that
there's a good chance that Denims will be a competitor. Did you
cover the allegation? I'm about to cover it right away. I don't
know about that >> pretty quick. Pretty quick.
>> We'll be covering it.
>> Yeah. So, you don't just get to declare. I I've
said in the law. Yeah. I guess you didn't read the lawsuit. Maybe
you should talk with Jaw. And you got absolutely eaten alive
here, dude. And you guys are always worried about getting mauled.
I'm actually I'll give you a little credit, though. You left
a tweet up to just remind everybody how dumb you are.
>> There's three pillars of fair use. fair
>> There's four pillars of fair use. Why did he say three?
>> Three pillars of fair use. >> Fair use.
>> He literally read Riyle's chat.
>> He literally read Rialy's chat and said three. There's
three. Where it says there's four.
How did he manage to do that? How did he say there's three when
he's reading a chat that says there's four. He read this symbol
as three. I'm That's amazing.
That actually takes talent.
>> I appreciate that. >> You point to mouse. He's
just
>> driving traffic isn't No, it's taking away. It's It's
like It's like if I were just to play Star Wars right now and
just let it fly and say, you know, uh I hate Kathleen Kennedy,
so don't give her company any money. I mean, get the [__]
out of here, Kyle. You're dumb as a
>> What are you doing with your life, by the way? I'd love
to know. >> They keep calling this guy Kyle. >> Like,
where are you going to school?
Are you just sitting around listening to the shut all day? >> Wait,
what? Hold on. Where does Tommy see getting off going, "Where
did you go to school?"
>> I don't think this guy makes money off his streaming.
I think he basically just off of his wife. Why? How the [__]
did he just say this?
>> I mean, he does say Jay-Z talk properly. Of all the
detractors, he says it intentionally up the least. Oh, sure.
I thought he was going to if he read the whole tweet, he would
just get to go if he just clicked on the text, he could see it.
Like all of the stuff I said, you don't need to be a lawyer to
understand that it's like frivolously included. He was so close.
But I think I, you know, I win because he says, what did what
did he say? >> I will just be >> there's no way that's
the reasoning, right? That they want to compare Hassan to this
guy donated.
Is this some there are four lights kind of going on here? >> Oh,
yeah. Maybe um Tommy C won't read the propaganda. Okay. Ry says
there's four lights.
Tommy se sees three. Okay, so he's going to say there are three
>> There are three lights. There are three lights. There
are three lights. At the very end of the torture, I have to confess
something. I did see four lights. Five four lights. Five lights.
I forget which one the actual the hallucination was. That is
that is the most disturbing fact of all. I I saw four lights.
You make a video that doesn't play Ethan's at all. Say, "Watch
this instead of the content nuke." And it would be a market replacement
by their logic. Oh yeah, exactly. Right. If Denims had not played
it and she said, "Hey guys, we're going live to replace this
content." Right. That would be a market replacement by their
logic. It's like you have to do the analysis of like what are
they replacing? And but by the
I think
fully I fully believe that she will fail the market replacement
analysis in some way. Right. I fully believe that because she
did stream large portions of the video with commentary, but not
like fully transformative commentary. It's not like she pre-filtered
it in any way and she was doing it, you know, she was doing it
on the fly like as it went live, competing with the stream and
probably the video to some extent. I think there's a lot of reasons
to believe she'll actually lose the case and and like lose the
copyright infringement case, but the malice is not going to be
a factor in it. It's going to be the the like dispassionate analysis
of the facts. she went live and live streamed at the same time
they were she was she was camping their live stream waiting for
it to go live right there were people advertising and pushing
towards her right there's a concern there's a campaign around
that and I don't know how much she'll be found you know responsible
for any damages from those people in being like uh pushing people
towards her but I do think it you know probably affects the bottom
line of whether or not it was a market replacement would Nick
Dario be against Dark Viper striking people if they did a full
reaction to Dark Viper's video criticizing them yes
the So
that's where the that's where the what would you call the critique
is not necessarily bad cuz Dark Viper is like DMCA and Chud,
right? And the DMCA on Chud is based on a full
and and Nicholas did did critique that. Now I will say probably
with DMC's as well, you have full leeway there. If your criteria
for a DMCA is I believe that you maliciously copied my stuff,
so you that's fine. You can DMCA based off of that, right?
If that was what if that was what Dark Viper believed if that
was what he said was you are maliciously doing this to take views
away from my video
then yeah I guess it depends right
there's sorry but there's no malicious statement from Chud sorry
Chud is trying to do good face transformative reacts that's the
difference
and Nicholas believes the Nicholas and Ethan and whoever they
believe that you can pick who you want and I I believe that too
you can pick who you want based on their statements if you state
that hey you I'm going to I'm going to reream your cuz you I
hate you, right? It's like, oh, I'm going to DMC that person,
but probably not somebody trying to react to it. That makes total
sense. That's fine. If people keep showing up to my house protesting
in the full in full nude and I call the cops on them, I'm not
sure how you can say I'm at fault for silencing my critics. Either
they're violating the law or not. Protest in legal ways.
>> Uh, no, that's not true, Zan Cali. So, I'm saying that
probably with regards to Chudlo Logic when he the reason he doesn't
take his DMCA case to court is because I think he believes he
will lose. He watched the full video. He did not preview it beforehand.
In in essence, his transformation is very similar to Denims's,
right? Just without the statement of malice. Like, there's a
decent chance he lose he loses that lawsuit. Oh, did I just No,
I didn't disable my mic. There's there's a very real chance he
loses that lawsuit. So, he doesn't want to take that lawsuit
to
>> right? But the crime is probably almost exactly the
same. It's very, very, very
Both, if you're going to say it's protesting elite, or sorry,
naked outside of their house, it would be like two people protested
naked, but one of them was like,
I'm here for a moral reason or I'm here because, you know, this
is my business. And the other one was like, you I hate you. I
just want you to see my when you come out of your house, right?
But you're trying to get them taken away for public indecency
or something. I don't know. I'm trying to make it analogous.
It's probably not necessarily analogous in some way. Yes. Uh
even if they fall outside of fair use, the clients are maliciously
using these lawsuits to punish their detractors. Yes. Yep. Which
is the whole thing. It's like, okay, I think if this lawsuit
goes through, the most concerning uh factor or the most concerning
outcome could be a chilling effect on criticism, critical views,
right? When you're when you're in big with somebody, when you're
sorry, when you're in good with somebody, when you're friends
with XQC or something, you don't care about him reacting to your
stuff on stream, right? And he's going to go, "Oh, this is awesome
because you guys are friends." But if somebody actually has a
criticism of your work and they want to review the whole thing,
well, now you've got license to sue them.
Which just seems like not correct to me.
>> As you can see, see what they're doing.
I told you it was coming
is uh they think there's going to be they want to they want to
support the bad empanadas of the world and and the denims of
the world and stuff like that. I guess they see money in it down
the road. >> Impression uh you cover any Nicholas clips
from tonight.
>> Can you pause for a quick second? But yeah, I I saw
one tweet by Shimu and I got the impression that
>> the good thing Nick stopped shouting these guys out
and all of a sudden they got angry >> just completely rattled
this guy and >> what I don't I think I think for a while
Queen was criticizing Nick and Nick was still shouting him out.
I don't think that's true. And Nick
didn't keep shouting me out. Nick and I had like a disagreement
and then he didn't like the the disagreements I put to Willie
and then he didn't want to talk. I don't think there was like
a like he stopped shutting me out and there was like no impetus.
>> Realized his all position has to start changing rapidly.
>> Uh I feel like there's a
significant chance he's like oh actually this will really m I
can't be near this guy. >> Yeah, I'm sure that's it. >> He
literally said like >> I mean that's another thing this
guy does all the time. Everybody's Everybody's stupid. >> I
mean, Willie Mack and Tommy C are stupid. I'm sorry. I would
talk to them about it if they wanted. They would like to talk
about it. We could. >> That That's all your arguments are.
You're stupid. You're dumb. I'm smarter than you.
>> He tried He tried to give Willie Mack a little bit of
wiggle room, but he's like, "Oh, yeah, man. I don't." >> He
also said that he actually roasted [__] five of you
at once, including what are you in there, Raten House? Kitten
House. >> Roasted five of you at once.
Just to be clear, and Willie lies about this for some reason.
The first thing he did was concede to me. I was like annoyed
that he was telling Kelly that she was insane about basically,
oh, you should fact check Destiny, right? Instead of just replplatforming
him, you fact check him cuz it makes your video better. And it's
just like the baseline journalistic integrity. So,
the first thing he does is concede to that argument. Hey, did
you ask him like if he had proof for this? And if he didn't,
isn't that like kind of interesting to you that he wouldn't have
any proof for this? He would just make it up, right? and Willie
Mack just immediately conceded. Oh yeah, the video would be better
if I if I did ask him for proof. Actually, that's a that's a
good criticism.
That was like the first thing. I don't It's like not even concerning.
And then the essence of the second criticism is that you're not
including the pattern of behavior, right, around the cherry stuff.
And then he very much like addresses that criticism in the second
video. In the second video he does. So, why would he why would
he make himself and also I believe
I believe he asks for evidence from Destiny based on for some
uh some of the stuff he's alleging. So, he addresses like criticisms
from that stream in the second video and fixes them. So, he can
say, "Oh, he roasted everybody, but he actually just wasn't intelligent
enough to respond to any of it and got Nick to sweep for him
and then fixed it after the fact and declared victory." Cool.
>> He got wrecked as well.
>> He got erected as well. What did he just >> He
got wrecked as well. >> You got wrecked as well. Okay.
Okay.
>> See, this is this is why I say this is why I say I like
Dan cuz I actually respect Dan more right now because Dan is
being honest. Dan is saying I am
>> No, no, no, no. We're going to the Lauren Southern stuff
right after this, guys. We'll we'll get to it right now. >> I
am lying. I hate her son and I am lying about him. Nick is here
pretending that Oh, I don't know. This is going a bit too far
for me now, guys. I think at this point, I'm finally deciding
all of a sudden when my friends start flipping and people look
really and everyone that's in the community that I came up in
is all of a sudden flipping on this position. Who the [__]
flipped? This is what Chad did to me. He's like he's constantly
changing his >> Wait, what? They just they just say that.
They don't give you an example.
>> No, it's that a bunch of people are calling this out
and a bunch of people are kind of like calling Ethan out now
for stuff. That's the flip. There's like a vibe change. There's
like a vibe shift that happened. That's the point. Not that like
Nick flipped some position or flip-flopped on something. I think
he always would have been against this. It's just about whether
here's what happens. If if Ethan does something I might principally
disagree with. I kind of just like ignore it and focus on some
other stuff, right? I don't make it loud. I might throw away
throw in like a you know, I don't necessarily disagree with this,
but these guys kind of deserve it. These guys are real.
That's like the issue that Queman is trying to get at there is
what Nick does is not, oh, I'm gonna like actually stand on my
principles and criticize this person close to me. He goes, uh,
I don't necessarily agree with it, but you know, I'm going to
go and uh, I'm going to go and talk about like howed up Denims
is,
Denims. Denims did CPS. I don't necessarily agree with it, but
like these people really suck. They called CPS on Ethan, okay?
I have no sympathy for them. They're pieces of [__]
And that's like a way of brushing over the fact that you just
did a criticism of any kind. Now, is that like something that
I'm looking for most of the time or something I super care about?
Not necessarily. But I also like won't disagree with Queen when
he says it. It's like probably true. >> Oh, now this is
slightly No, it's definitely true. I don't know why I said >> too
far for me. He's doing this whole minstrel show of a commentary
YouTuber where all of a sudden >> he's doing blackface
in a serious job known as YouTube drama commentary.
What happened to dorks and weirdos? >> He pretends that
this is like, oh, this lie is too far. I know Dan's been lying
for the whole last two years and half the content nuc lies, but
>> lies, dumb, stupid, anything but an
What did someone >> Wait, hold on. There are lots of
that that we I think we literally pulled up examples like on
this stream, didn't we?
But ah man. Okay, I'm gonna keep >> I think it was a bot.
>> Was this guy reacting? >> Just a dishonest rumor
bill. Someone a bot wrote me that. I was like, "Oh, I Yeah, he's
kind of right. Absolutely kind of right." Okay, >> that's
all we got. >> They're They're They're under the impression
sit.
But I recommend you don't because I got to be honest with you,
not talking to Aiden, not talking to Jenna has brought so much
funny content. >> It has in their stupid We'll have a debate.
I mean, >> you've given me a debate. >> Wait, we're
dude. Yeah, we're the No. No. He's so right. He's so right. The
funny part is that we look ridiculous. And not that he's just
like been caught saying stuff that's like so laughably untrue.
Sometimes you actually have to question if he's genuinely psychotic
or if it's a meme. But no, like he he full-blown means it. Yeah,
he knows this stuff is untrue, but he's saying it anyways because
when he says something wrong, he cannot back down on it and he'll
defend it like forever. >> And we have we'll have it out.
It's just And first of all, they're probably gonna have 20 guys
jump in on you anyway. But >> yeah, I'm jumping in. This
is too [__] funny. So apparently I don't know Queen
and I haven't heard this >> I'm not talking to them. I'm
not like engaging in like any environment where I may be like
exposed to like hostile opinions in a live format where I don't
have total control of the room. I'm not engaging in that not
because I'm like a illiterate like unintelligent
that like can't actually defend my own positions. I'm doing that
to own them. I'm doing that for the content. Yeah, you are. Yeah,
we all believe you, bro. We all believe you, bro. here. >> I
hate this miserable fat gay alcoholic old loser and the way he
just wants to ride on wheel.
>> I've known him both for 8 years. I know. I know everybody
I know everybody is just content waiting in the waiting. >> Literally
his only motive for going >> Oh, everyone to him is just
content in the waiting. No, what >> is to ride these guys
raw? That's his only motive for going live. >> I could
say the same about you. How Queman literally I don't watch Queenman's
coverage because half of it is like and this is good by the way
but half of it is like stuff that's totally unrelated to like
this specific community. A lot of it he like covers like specific
politics, specific debates that have nothing to do with this
community. It like gives like his own like original thoughts
instead of like defending the preconceived thoughts like sured
by others. He engages in debates. He engages in critical push
back. Um, I don't know how you could like ever watch a Queenman's
stream and come to that >> I mean, >> you could say
the same thing about him. It would just be wrong, right? You
can say anything, but it's just wrong. And whether or not something
is verifiably wrong or not doesn't really like matter to you
when you say it there. Like there are numerous verifiable instances
where you're just spouting complete and utter [__]
It's it's re it's really funny cuz he said Nick the other day
is is infamous for riding somebody else than the way up. By the
way, the best it's the Keemstar principle and these guys are
laying it out for you. They're riding Chud, but they have a problem
and they haven't figured it out yet, but I'll explain it to you
how he thinks me like at the beginning a lot of Que's exposure
was from Chud, but Chud hasn't rated Quimman anytime recently,
right? And they're not like doing a whole lot together. I'm not
rid I barely talked to Chud. Like I barely spoken to Chad in
the last few weeks. We talk, you know, we're we're we're acquaintances,
colleagues on this ship. I I'm not, you know, um I'm not in any
group chats with him. I'm not like I I I talked to him occasionally,
right? Um I'm not riding him. I don't think Queman is either.
Is Queman's wigler supposed to look like a young Tommy C? Uh
I don't think so. I don't know. Maybe it's supposed to look like
he's on vacation or something. I don't know. Summer to summer
Avatar ever. It's the most pathetic subhuman [__]
ever. >> Doesn't like you. Ry doesn't like you,
>> Yeah. Yeah. Riyle had a meltdown in my chat. I think
I'm going to post it now. >> They're melting down. I'm
getting the content. It's them that are melting. Dude, like I
know he doesn't believe this, which just makes it all the more
funnier cuz it's just like to It's like the most like obvious
form of cope I've ever seen. It's like it's literally like Bob
saying, "I don't watch the coverage. I don't watch any of the
coverage about me. He has to pretend like the sentiment and that
doesn't make him any more wrong or right. Right. Like Tommy can
have the majority against him and still be correct. But he's
pretending like the majority isn't against him. Not only is the
majority against you, but multiple things you've said are verifiably
wrong. And I' and Tommy, I think at one point of the stream said
it's always like opinions like you're [__] you're
this, but nobody uh engage. He doesn't say nobody engages the
point cuz he doesn't have a vocabul. He says something that is
synonymous with that, right? And it's like, what the are you
talking about? Like I literally So you couldn't say I wasn't
engaging with the point. I literally said, "Here is every single
time I think you've lied. Why it's a lie?" Except like I've I've
laid out my points against you so many times that to my audience,
it's just going to be repetitive. But when you say it, I'm probably
going to do it again. >> He's mad that I called him a sweeper
for Jical. You're talking about Yeah, exactly. You can do it
both ways. You guys sweep for Jical and Do it. You can. You can
do it. Wait. Wait. What did he Is that lie number? Is that lie
number? What lie number? We need like a lie count. I just found
his new lie. Tommy made a tweet saying spicy chat because spicy
chat is the word for what he thinks is the queen in Jto, etc.
Crew, right? But he said spicy chat is going to sweep for JTO.
So I reply said like along lines of this isn't true. This is
stupid. Because spicy chat were some of the most vocal people
about calling him out yet. And his response was, "Oh, well, that's
an obvious joke. You can't like it's a joke. I'm joking." As
if like that wasn't he wasn't making an actual point there, right?
And now he's reiterating the same point that I had previously
addressed against him on Twitter that he tried to refute by saying
it's a joke. Here he is actively saying it again. So you lied
that it was just a joke as if there wasn't a serious underlying
point because here you are spouting that point again. And I sweep
for Nick. Even though what you do, I actually point out like
when I did with Chud and I told you how he did Turkey Tom dirty
dirty and how he knew about the outcome when he was arguing or
the way I pointed out the Boback thing when he made he's given
like five different stories and had help. Yeah, it looked awful.
Why are they such? Just like what you can't even talk to Riyle.
You can't even debate Riyle. He brings up, okay, obviously when
you're recounting something that happened that isn't on record
like from months ago, like when did we find out about the Boak
stuff? When did such when did a given person find out about the
Boak stuff? Right? Obviously, when you're going back and remembering
that the details of that conversation and it's not on record,
you're going to the answer will change and you'll not like you'll
say something like I think it was or I think it was and that
will change, right? because you're trying to actively go back
and remember something. >> Ryle Riyle, if I remember correctly,
was he the guy who's like, "Anyone wanted to glitch Jennifer
Pis?" I'm not talking to that guy. >> He he he put Okay,
Riyle's soy as But he put Ry He did he put Riyle's like uh he
gave him like a soy voice. So, he won >> That That was
the guy that just her
>> They're demanding S man. >> S man. S man's not
even a thing. You're [__] too low here, pal. You
need Chud to back you. You said what? He Nobody needs Chud to
back Queman certainly doesn't need Chud to back him. I don't
need Chud to back me, right? But Queean is like the last person
you could [__] say that about. What are you talking
about? Queimman could turn on Chud tomorrow and he would still
have a sizable audience. What the are you talking about? >> Well,
for Chud, not S man. I don't know S man. He just calls in. You
look older than me.
>> Oh, he just Okay, so it's it's guilt by association.
It's guilt by association
when when I know so I run with a crew that has a guy that accused
Tommy of sending dupics 14-year-olds. The problem is what crew
is that? What guy is that? And when do I talk to that guy? And
when did that guy seriously make an accusation of you sending
a dickpick to a 14-year-old? You're doing guilt by association
with built on false premises. Right. But if somebody can do guilt
if if it's if it could be guilt by association with you, you're
just like he's a guy that just calls in taken seriously. But
these guys immediately like blow gas. I did that to Chad Logic
and like immediately it's like s is so
>> I I literally he's like s man called it >> persistent
guy who appears on shows. You're not just some random chatter.
You're not just like a random account. >> Actually is you
know Willie in [__] chat saying uh you know AIDS
gang owns you Tommy and then Tommy loses his [__]
mind. You are a persistent who is out there making >> good
points. Good points. >> Arguments for your opinions. Saying
>> These guys sound like the MVR chatter guys. Taking themselves
so seriously. It's too funny. >> These guys are being serious.
>> That's his He can't It's like He's like a He's literally
like a rock. He's like a rock. He just He He can't I don't know
what what to call this. It's like he can't enga. Why are you
even watching this? He is so [__] unintelligent and
so stupid. And that's not to say that any of us are exceptionally
intelligent. We're just all probably of average intelligence,
right? But a normal person can like listen to something someone's
saying and like address it and engage with it. Tommy can't. So
his response is, "You're taking this seriously.
I'm just laughing. I'm just I made a bunch of like cope streams
about Chun because I I don't take this serious. I crashed out
on you for sending the most like the most like try not to off
somebody word a DM ever. I crashed out on you uh because I don't
take any of this YouTube seriously. Like you can't have it both
ways. You can't be litigating your points and and standing by
them as if as if you're being serious and then anytime people
respond to you do the whole laughing bad they take this seriously.
Like you can't play both sides at once without looking like a
total [__] dishonest, which is what you are, right?
>> You have opinions and their opinions and they need to
be challenged. Here's the thing. Don't talk to any of these guys.
First of all, they're ridiculous people and all they can do is
just say, "You're stupid. No, you're stupid. No, you're >> No.
Well, engage with your points. I'll do way more. I'll do way
more than what you're able to do. No, I I my my points I call
you stupid because that's what you are, but I could do a whole
stream about you without ever using that word or any word that's
synonymous with it, right? I don't I could I could do a whole
stream without doing ad hom against you and I could still make
it would still be of significant length because I could engage
with how dishonest your points are and then packing off cuz you're
a complete [__] Yes, people are going to say to you,
"Hey, why do you think that? Justify that to me." >> Oh,
Jesus Christ. I'm going to justify to you. How about I say and
you can comment on if you feel like it if you have anything else
to say but from what I can see is you look at the chat and that's
where you get your opinion. >> He used this this is what
he you know he's making this up on the spot. He's using the same
criticism for me. This is how you know he's trying to come up
with [__] cuz he can't like look into like what would
be a valid criticism because Queman is literally Queman argues
with his chat all the time. He used the same criticism on me.
I argue with this chat constantly. You could find like you could
find like 20 parts from every stream where I'm arguing in some
in the chat. I have people call in from the chat to argue with
me. Unfortunately, not many like to. Right. But the the notion
that someone is he saw me reading chat once. He's like, "That's
right, Aiden. Get all your opinions from the chat." As if that
like which is a total self-report by the way cuz that's the only
reason he could think someone reads a chat. Not cuz hey, let
me go like interact with my viewers, see what thoughts they're
contributing on this, etc., etc. No, it's let me look for what
opinions I'm going to steal to him. That's what he thinks that
is, right? But no, this is a ridiculous criticism for anybody
who who does a who's done a shred of research into who Quan is
and who I am. You don't even need to do research. You could just
skip through a stream and see that's clearly not the case. They
naturally think we got to say uh we we have to uh we have to
change course. We have to do something different. We have to
get on a new wave like Assan. But they've backed Ethan a little
bit here and there. So they got they can't they can't come out
and look as ridiculous as Frooen and Assad. So they have to they
think there's some kind of [__] middle ground there.
The middle ground. >> He thinks everything is being done
superficially. Like people can't just like formulate their own
opinions without like worrying about how those opinions are being
perceived. He's acting like oh they like they go after Assad
but then they kind of defend Ethan so that they could look a
bit different from No. It's called having nuance you [__]
It's called assessing. It's called not playing team sports and
like having nuance and like assessing that there aren't really
good guys and bad guys all the time and there are specific things
that Ethan can do wrong and there is specific things can do wrong.
That's called nuance. You're just discovering this concept I
guess >> on his neck. And here's what they don't get. And
this is super funny. I saw this coming a while ago. So I call
that >> I saw I predicted it. Dude, Nostradamus d he's
doing the Nostradamus thing again. Okay. He just gets he he he
act he thinks he's like a prophet. He predicts like everything
and like when two of those predictions come right, he acts like
he has all this great ins. You don't actually. You don't. He
keeps saying this guy's going to drop out when I Listen, Tommy.
Listen, Tommy. When I get my degree, I'm going to I'll invite
you to my graduation at college. I'll invite you. You'll have
a front row seat. Okay? No, you won't. I can't guarantee that.
But I will unironically send you an invite, Tommy, when I graduate.
And now obviously you won't pull up. But I'll post a picture
of my diploma and you can look at it and cry realizing that I
didn't drop. Not only did I not drop out, you're still a dropout.
You didn't go back to school. You didn't get a degree. You started
something and you failed at it because you're a big fat failure.
At least Tommy is good-looking. He's lo No, he has abdominal
obesity. So he's carrying most of the weight around his abdomen.
>> Chud, I knew you were setting the table for him, right?
So I called out Chud. So it's a lot more difficult to set the
table. Now when you go and back Queenman Queen, by the way, you
need Chud to move to the next level. >> He doesn't. Not
Not really. No. >> As this is the way >> a lot of
Chud's audience just doesn't like Quimman, right? Wasn't like
a big thing for a while. Quean kind of has his own independent
audience. It's like a mix of like XDG people. You had some people
come over from Chud. You There is overlap. I'm not going to pretend
like there isn't some overlap there, but no, Quimman is not relying
on Chud obviously >> works. I'm giving you the the actual
>> If Queman turned on Shod, he would maintain around the
same viewers he has now viewership he has now. He might maybe
lose some of the active fans, but both Queean and Shod have like
built a reputation upon being able to criticize your friends
and have independent thoughts, right? So that audience certainly
wouldn't turn on Queean if he had an independent thought or opinion
about Chud. >> This whole thing, this is how the whole
[__] thing works. Chud needs to back Quean to move
up. >> Oh. Oh, wait. Chud needs to Chad needs back Queen
for Queenman to move. Okay, >> so the idea was to attack
Nick. Chud >> Wait, what? Excuse me. >> Can't attack
Nick yet because the table's not set. So, it's Queenman's job
to get everybody rolling and moving up to the top. And then and
then you'll see Ch, well, I don't know. I I think Queman's right
here. And what have you. What? Dude, what is this guy? He unironically
just assumes that this is how people operate. He can't just imagine
somebody sits down every day and then independently formulates
an opinion on something and gives coverage about it without conspiring
behind the scenes. This concept is foreign to him because that's
what him and his little butt buddies have done for years. And
they hate people like Quean for it because he's independent of
all that. They hate people like Chud for it because Chud will
[__] on you whether you're his friend or not, right?
Because he'll give an he'll give an opinion on you that's negative
whether you're his friend or not. This is like a foreign concept
that he's literally This is a lot of this is just total projection.
He's assuming because him and his guys have operated a certain
way for so long. That must be how everyone else is thinking.
That must be how everyone else is operating. >> You know,
play stupid like he normally does. But it's a problem because
I came out and pointed out what a backstabbing snake this guy
was. It's going to be a >> a backstabbing snake. It's YouTube
drama, man. It's just you Why are you taking YouTube, Dude? He's
a backstabbing snake, dude. Why does this guy take it so seriously?
It's just YouTube drama, bro. You need to calm down and like
go outside, spend some time with the wife. Seems like you're
taking all this YouTube bit too
>> Little bit difficult.
The best part is too crew is just >> the Queenman crew.
Dude, I love this is like new thing as well. >> Filled
with leaks. Aren't I right, Lumpy >> Wait, he thinks Lumpy
Queman's crew. Queensman's crew, bro. >> Yeah, you know
I'm right, Lumpy Willie. Everybody talks. They're all talking
behind each other's back. They're all trying to clip each other
and eventually it gets in my ear. >> No, we're not talking
behind each other's back. Okay, Queman will say
like a disagreement on me in someone's chat yesterday. Nobody's
going behind each other's back. They're saying it outright and
in private, but they say it outright. This part is also a projection.
You went behind my back. You had a problem with me. didn't let
me know you had that problem and then went to others behind my
back not talking to me about it. Right? And you say, "I've known
Willie and Nick for eight years. I've known you for eight years,
too. You never not once decided to bring that up to me, right?
You just went behind my back about it where you could poison
the well for other people and not give me a chance to address
it. And somehow you're going to pretend like that's not snaky."
>> So they can't defend Bobax anymore and they can't attack
Nick. >> Yeah. Quan thinks I'm some Puritan that has like
some lever aversion. >> So what these guys have tried >> that's
not true by the way >> is charge forward hoping hoping
that Chud won't will actually back them one point one day but
they're not he can't do it he can't do it so they think they
think they got this is this is such projection I've never you
know what Nick probably vented to Tommy in private that he felt
like Chud was snaking him Tommy jumped the gun doing the Chud
coverage and he was expecting Nick to come in and back him Nick
never came in and backed him and at some point Tommy literally
had to say he lost. That is quite literally what happened with
you? What are you talking about? It's like total projection something
over on everybody but they don't. And here's the other thing
and the reason they want because I'm sorry you guys are just
not that talented. The influencers can't
>> So what do they do next? I can't influence. I can't
move up. I've got to attack the guy above me. >> I don't
do that. I don't attack. I barely talk. People say in my chat
say I sweep for Nick. I don't do I know he's not just talking
about me. He like lumps everybody in together, but Quimman covers
non- Nick related stuff almost always. Most Queman bit his tongue
about Nick for a while. I'm not going at the I'm not going at
anyone that's above me. So what how am I compensating for what
you would interpret as a lack of talent. His laughing and yelling
when he thinks he's a good No, the laughing is he knows it's
not The problem with Tommy is he's he is actually aware of some
of this stuff. The laughing is when he knows that someone is
a good point against him or he doesn't have a good point. So,
it's like a way to compensate and make the opponent look ridiculous.
The why that doesn't work is that Tommy doesn't know how to match
that level of laughing. So, it's at like a realistic level. So,
the fake laughing comes off as like very obviously fake because
it is fake. Uh, and just like looks like total coping, right?
So, if he were to like look at the statement I just made about
the way he laughs, he would look at that, start laughing, and
say, "I take this too seriously." That's the when he has no point,
he falls back on laughing at something that nobody else would
ever find funny. Uh or accusing the person making the point of
taking this too seriously while simultaneously
um himself litigating drama against someone in a serious manner.
Uh and then saying, "Oh, don't take it seriously. Just YouTube
drama.